RETO MEIER: Good
day, everybody.
And welcome to this
week's show.
I'm Reto Meier.
IAN NI-LEWIS: And I'm Ian
Needlessly Angry Lewis.
RETO MEIER: This week, we're
going to be taking a look at
news reader apps so I can keep
up with that story about the
dingo and the baby.
IAN NI-LEWIS: And I'm going to
be drinking in all that stuff
on the latest whiskey news.
RETO MEIER: This week on--
[INTERPOSING VOICES].
RETO MEIER: Today, we're looking
at news apps, News
Republic from Mobiles Republic
and The Verge from Vox Media.
I'm going to be flying solo
today as Ian recovers from his
needlessly angriness.
We'll then dig a little deeper
and learn some of the tricks
you can use to make your news
apps even more engaging.
And in particular, we're going
to be looking at how to use
precaching and analytics to
really serve up relevant,
timely news without draining the
battery or sucking up all
of your bandwidth.
So news apps have always
been amongst the most
popular apps on mobile.
So you'd expect that at this
point, they were pretty
well-polished.
And to a large degree,
this is true.
There's a great range of
polished, intuitive apps that
deliver timely and relevant news
articles both in the form
of aggregators, like News
Republic, or single-source,
optimized apps like The Verge.
And so these are the sorts of
things which we come to expect
from any decent news
app these days.
It shouldn't drain
the battery.
It should deliver timely,
relevant news.
And it should really have
an easy-to-use UI.
At this point, the expectations
around the user
interface for a news app are
pretty well understood.
We've moved beyond that really
simple ListView, forced
refresh type approach to
something much more engaging
with rich media.
And so that's the sort of things
which we're expecting
from our apps.
Now, that means that user
expectations, because they're
so much higher now, it's no
longer good enough to have
something which is just a
janky ListView that only
updates when you hit Refresh.
These days, users are really
expecting something more
refined, something that really
stands out from the crowd, or
it's but the work of but a
moment to head back to Google
Play and find something better,
something which has
more of the news that you want
in a much nicer user
experience.
So there's a variety of
options to help your
news app stand out.
Now, some of my favorites
include the clever use of
notifications and the ability
to customize my news feed,
even without having to log in.
And so these are some of the
additional extras that we can
really use to boost your app.
So smart notifications,
customization without logging
in, and, of course, widgets
as well, having a nice,
resizable, engaging widget,
which is becoming, more and
more, a must-have for
your news apps.
So let's take a closer look at
two apps in particular, News
Republic and The Verge, before
looking at how you can
implement some of these more
advanced features yourself.
Now, News Republic is currently
my go-to news source.
So it's fair to say
that I'm a fan.
As you can see, their landing
page in Google Play is pretty
good, although I do wish that
they'd change their icon to
something a little more
distinctive rather than using
this variation of the old
rounded square approach,
particularly as they
already have a
really distinctive logo.
And you can see that
within their logo
in both places here.
It's got this News
Republic icon.
And I think it would be really
interesting to explore that a
little bit further and see what
they could do to make
that a bigger part of both
the icon and the
overall feature graphic.
Speaking of the feature graphic,
it's pretty good, but
perhaps a little bit too
detailed to really work well
when you shrink it down into
some of our smaller feature
graphic spots.
I'd be really interested to see
a variation here that's a
little bit more stylized,
perhaps losing the content of
the papers here while still
maintaining that same
stylistic look and feel.
Similarly, within the logo
itself, maybe having larger
text, dropping the logo,
specifically,
from the feature graphic.
I think both of those things
could tend to make it a little
bit more engaging, particularly
as we make it smaller.
But really, that's nitpicking.
And a lot of the comments that I
have for News Republic today
are along those nit-picky lines,
because it really is a
really well-polished app.
And they've done a great deal
of work here to make it
something that works really,
really well.
So this here is my News
Republic home screen.
And as you can probably tell,
I've customized it a little
with Google, Android, and UL top
stories all there on the
front page.
Now, if we switch to the giant
phone, you can see that
they've implemented a number
of really nice transition
animations when switching
between topics.
So I click here onto
top stories.
You'll see it all flies out
before filling it all in.
And you can see it's got that
nice intro in animation.
So every time you move around
the app, everything floats and
flies with you, which
is really nice.
Everything slides
in, slides out.
You can see that again.
Get rid of the interstitial.
The interstitial ads do take
longer to display, which is
interesting.
I guess if I had to make a
choice between the ads taking
too long to display or the news
articles, I would prefer
that the news articles
are faster.
And that is the way that
it works, though those
interstitials can be a little
bit frustrating at times.
So let's have a look.
You can also see that once
you're within a particular
topic, they've implemented a--
once you're reading each
particular article, I should
say, the first time through, you
get told how to interact
with it, which is probably
a good thing.
And you can see here, they've
got the standard view page and
model for swiping between apps,
which is really nice.
And up here at the top here, you
can see the disappearing,
reappearing tab headers.
So you can see how far through
a particular topic you are,
which is really nice.
It follows their standard UI
guidelines while putting its
own personalized take on that.
And of course, probably one of
the most impressive animations
that they've got within the app
is there signature topic
search cloud that's implemented
really nicely.
So if I click up here, their
search cloud icon, and you can
see I get this really nice
search cloud for all of the
topics which are discussed
within a particular article.
So you can scroll along here and
then use this the way you
would scroll Wikipedia and say,
oh, actually, I want to
look at Google articles.
You click on that.
And it will take you straight
to that sublist
of the Google stuff.
And you can do this as you're
going within each topic, or
within each article to further
dig within that topic group.
And they've actually got a few
different approaches here.
So you can have a square.
Or you can have a scrolling
hoop, I suppose you'd say.
So they've got some really
nice animations here.
And it really creates a really
rich and engaging experience
which really encourages you to
keep exploring within the app,
which is a really key thing
within a news app.
You really want to keep people
jumping from article to
article, reading as much as
possible without exiting your
app because they're bored or
they've read what they've come
to look at.
Now, in particular, I think News
Republic does two really
difficult things really well.
So if we switch back to the
slides, I'll demonstrate what
I'm talking about.
Beautiful.
So what you can see, first off,
they've implemented a
really excellent breaking
news notification.
This doesn't trigger too often
for me, maybe two,
three times a day max.
So it's not intrusive.
It doesn't make me feel as
though it's running in the
background, draining my
battery all the time.
But it does pop up.
And it does remind me of
breaking news as it happens.
And then the actual
implementation of the
notification is really,
really good.
It's a rich notification
straight off.
So it's got an image.
It has a generous snippet of
news, so I can actually read
what that breaking news headline
is, and not just the
headline, but actually the
article lead to know whether
it's something which I
want to read further.
And what they've done really
well to get that bonus point
is that they've actually let me
interact with it directly
from the notification.
So you can see I can share
directly from here, or,
indeed, indicate my mood, the
way that this article makes me
feel, which is another
killer feature for
News Republic here.
They really encourage users
to signal the mood
evoked by each article.
And they let me do this without
having to log in.
So basically, once I start
up, I can log in.
I can choose to give them
credentials so that my
preferences are persistent
across devices and logins.
But without having to do
anything, I can straight away
start to interact and tell
them what my mood is.
And why is this important?
Well, this lets them, then,
customize the things which I
want to hear about.
So my breaking news
notifications, even the news
feed itself, can all be
optimized around the articles
which I interact with.
In particular, it gives you
an idea of what kind of an
article it is, whether people
are surprised, angry, sad,
happy, which is useful
in and of itself.
But apart from that, it's just
a signal that people are
interested enough in a
particular article
to engage with it.
So that gives them really useful
analytics that they can
use for a number of
different things.
Now, they can use that feedback
to either choose
which notifications
I'm using or to
customize the feed directly.
Now, overall, I think News
Republic have done these
things really, really well.
There's really little jank.
I really seldom find myself
waiting for images or articles
to download.
And the UI offers some really
unique features, such as their
subject cloud, without deviating
too far from the
standard UI guidelines.
I never feel like I'm lost
within the app, unsure of how
to do something or how
to get somewhere.
It's all where I expect it to
be with the occasional happy
surprise of something I
wasn't expecting but
I'm happy to see.
Now, there are a couple of areas
where I'd like to see
them adhere a little more
closely to the UI guide.
And in particular, it's
really centered
around the action bar.
So you can see here that they've
created their own
action bar implementation,
which is totally fine and
understandable if you want to
have backwards compatibility
and not have to have too many
different versions of the app.
But some of their choices are
a little bit jarring to an
experienced Android user.
So in particular, the overflow
menu is pretty nonstandard.
And you can see here, the size
of each menu item is
slightly too large.
Separator lines are
a little too dark.
And all the text is
right-aligned, which is off.
They should all be
left-aligned.
And they've added icons, which
is really nonstandard.
So there's nothing particularly
wrong about the
way this looks except that
it doesn't look the
way I expect it to.
So when I hit it, it creates
this cognitive dissonance
moment of, OK, this isn't
what I was expecting.
And so whenever you're
surprising your users with
something that they're not
expecting, that can break them
out of their engagement,
make them second
guess themselves, almost.
It's like, oh, did I
do something wrong?
I was expecting this to happen
and something else did.
You want to avoid those
circumstances where you're
forcing users to question their
own behavior as that's
going to make them less
confident, make them less
willing to explore your
app and find some
of the hidden gems.
And in fact, it goes that little
one step further within
the action bar itself.
You can see that once you go
beyond the menu to the actual
action bar icons, in particular
the mood and share
icons, they're also a
little non-standard.
They're a bit too dark.
The overflow menu item itself
looks a lot like the standard
overflow menu but
isn't quite it.
It's too dark.
The dots are slightly too big.
So again, we're talking really
slight variation, but just
enough to be a little
bit disconcerting.
So it's fair to say
that all this
has been pretty nit-picky.
But it's small details like this
that are like having sand
in your bathers.
It's small, but constantly
irritating.
So it would be great to see
the team, perhaps, work on
those things.
But overall, a really
fantastic app.
Like I said, I go to a
news app every day.
So I'm a big fan.
Now The Verge, as opposed to
News Republic, which is a
content aggregator, The Verge
is a single-source news app
that effectively wraps
a popular tech
news site, The Verge.
And we figured that The Verge
spends enough time talking
about us that it might
be fun to talk a
little bit about them.
So we'll start off with their
landing page, which is great.
It's got a distinctive logo
which everyone recognizes.
And its feature graphic
is really stand out.
Now personally, I think they may
have overdone the padding
and transparency a little bit
so that the actual logo and
words are a little bit small on
the feature graphic here.
I'd think about making that
a little more opaque and a
little bit bigger, just so that
when we shrink it down to
some of the smaller feature
slots on a phone, it's still
legible and recognizable.
Now, single-source apps tend
to be a bit of a mixed bag.
It's not uncommon to see
companies having an intern
wrap their RSS feed in a
ListView and call it a day.
Because people are passionate
readers of a particular site,
they will download the app
and use it no matter what
the UX and UI is.
But it's just not going to give
them a great experience.
And you got to remember that
your app, your Android app,
your mobile app, is a
representation of your
website, of your brand,
more importantly.
So if you're going to go to the
effort of building an app,
you need to make sure that it's
something that represents
your brand in a positive way.
Good news is that The Verge
have done that.
It is a good app.
They've done a great job.
It's a simple design, but very
intuitive, as it should be.
One of the advantages of a
single-source app like this is
that you don't need to figure
out how to incorporate lots of
different sections from lots of
different news sources with
potentially different styles of
writing, different styles
of layout, different
styles of imagery.
It all comes from your site,
so you can be much more
aggressive in your assumptions
as to the way you'll be
getting the information and the
way that that information
should be displayed.
So you can see right off the bat
they've separated the app
into three sections using a
standard view page that works
really well.
So you can swipe between those
three main topics.
And again, this front page is
really nice and engaging.
You've got big, rich graphics.
Particularly the top story has
that full bleed image in the
background.
In fact, it may even be worth
considering doing that more.
If you have that ability, if you
have the ability to know
what graphics you're going to
get, what format that they're
in because it's your site, it
can create a really engaging
experience if you make that
front page just graphics,
graphics, graphics, full
bleed with headline
text over the top.
Now, you do need to be careful
to weigh that up against
readability.
It's no use having a
great-looking front page if no
one can read the articles
if that's the point.
But it's something to consider,
perhaps trying to
make what we've got here for the
lead article more common
throughout the ListView.
They've also implemented the
draw pattern the right way,
which is always nice to see.
And this is an alternative here
that uses an alternative
for hiding options that you
might otherwise expect to see
in the overflow menu.
I think that works really well,
particularly for the
additional navigation options,
going between
sections and so on.
It really lets them have that
really clean front page with
just the three swipers
rather than having
endless different sections.
But I'm not sure it's the right
place for things like
Account and About.
And I can see that you've put
them here so that all the
navigation options
are in one place.
But personally, I think they
would be better off back in
the overflow menu, away from the
rest of the navigation, so
that this stays as clean
as possible.
I think that's a really good
theme, overall, whenever
you're building that navigation
structure for your
app is you want to try and give
people as few options as
possible whenever possible.
So if there are things like
Account and About which need
to be in the app, and if people
want them, they'll find
them, but this is a good example
where they may be
better off away from this
other, more standard
navigation.
There's a lot of really nice
touches in the app.
I particularly like the way that
they've handled comments
and updates for stories
really intuitively.
You've got things like if
there are updates to the
stories, then the actual
ListView will have those
updates underneath.
And you're able to swipe
through to get them.
Really tidy.
Same with comments.
They've got a separate page.
Using the standard action bar
for adding comments and a
standard ListView for reading
them looks really nice.
Now, there's maybe one or two
exceptions to things which are
done the right way.
And I think, most notably, is
once you have drilled into a
topic and you're reading an
article, it's not possible to
swap between the articles
within a topic.
The way that we saw earlier
in News Republic
worked really well.
So that would be really nice
to see something like that.
And the reason for that is--
now, I don't want to
have to navigate
back out to the topic.
It breaks that flow.
And it's back to what I
was saying earlier.
When you're building a news app,
you really want to keep
people reading as long
as possible.
And every time they have to
click, it's one more step.
It's that little bit longer.
So you want to reduce the number
of clicks between any
given action for a user
to get what they want.
And so that ability to swipe
through articles the way that
you would flip the pages of a
newspaper is a really good
metaphor, and it's one which
people are used to from
reading, whether it be books,
magazines, or newspaper.
This idea of getting to a
section and then just being
able to swipe through
article after
article is really familiar.
So I think it would be really
great to see something like
that implemented here
using a view pager.
And this segues nicely into the
first of my more generic
recommendations for building
engaging news apps.
Now, number one is you really
want to be using analytics.
Now, I've highlighted here the
Google Analytics for Android
applications' website.
But really, it can be this.
It can be something homegrown.
It can be something
else entirely.
But what you want to be doing is
tracking really closely the
actions that your users
are taking.
This can be completely
anonymized.
It's not important that you
understand who it is and what
they've done.
Really, you just want to get a
glimpse into how things are
working, which topics are
popular, which articles are
being fully read, which topics
are people reading all
the articles in.
That's going to give you a lot
of really rich information
that you can use to customize
that feed and make that use
more and more relevant.
So the best way to do this is
just the first time the app
starts up to assign it a UUID,
just a random, universally
unique identifier so that you're
able to keep track of
what people are doing in a way
that allows you to customize
their news feed accordingly.
So you can do that in
a couple of ways.
So once you've got that
information and you understand
what someone's reading habits
are-- and it's important, as
well, to make sure that people
understand that you're doing
this so that they know that you
are keeping track of what
they're reading if you plan
to do it in a way that is
personalized to them.
So first off, you can customize
the notifications
and, potentially, their
widget contents.
So these are the things which
you're pulling out to
specifically highlight to them
either on their homescreen
widget or within these broadcast
alert notifications.
Now, this is really important
because it lets you tailor
that content to something that
they're likely to want to see.
And this is really important
for notifications.
If you're going to be popping
something up, interrupting
their flow, you want to make
sure it's something that
they're going to be
interested in.
So understanding what topics
they have selected, what
articles they tend to read, is
a really powerful tool for
being able to do that.
Now, you can take this a step
further and aggregate all the
results server-side.
And this may, in fact, be an
even better option, in some
cases, than trying to make it
to customized, to find out
what is everyone reading, what
are the articles that everyone
is clicking, everyone is
reading through, and
potentially, what are
they all sharing.
And that is probably something
which everyone else is going
to be interested in.
So you can take those aggregated
server-side results
and use it to use
cloud-to-device messaging to
ping everyone that this is an
article that they may want to
read and pop up a notification
accordingly.
Now, you can then expand this
beyond a single article to
help decide which articles
to prefetch.
Now, we've talked about
prefetching before.
Particularly for something like
news, it's a really great
way to help reduce latency,
improve offline support, and
reduce the battery cost of
getting those regular updates.
It's really a way of you being
able to figure out what is the
user going to need in the next
two to five minutes.
Well, get it all now.
So then, as soon as they
click on something,
it's already there.
They don't have to
wait at all.
There's also a significant
battery cost associated with
turning on the cell radio in
order to download things.
So you want to try and bundle
all of that together.
And prefetching is a great way
of being able to take all of
the articles which you think
they may read, pre-downloading
them so that you don't
have to do it each
time they click one.
Now, if you know what articles
or topics that a user is
likely to actually read,
including the frequency at
which they're likely to read it,
you stand a great chance
of downloading the right data
at the right time and really
have a dramatic impact on
battery life while also
reducing that latency
to nearly zero.
So that lets you aggressively
prefetch, making sure that you
always have fresh articles to
read and reducing that latency
when you click a headline.
So it's a really
great approach.
And you can see here a code
snippet which lets you vary
the amount of data that you're
downloading based on the cell
radio connection that you have,
which really boils down
to the faster the radio, the
more data you should download
when your prefetching.
So now that you're using
analytics and prefetching, you
run the risk of draining the
battery due to too frequent
radio state transitions.
So to minimize this, you need
to bundle all your transfers
as much as possible.
Now, analytics is a long game.
Your algorithms don't need to
be working out, every click,
how does this change the next
thing that we download.
It really wants to be
working on large
corpuses of user data.
So there's no particular urgency
to getting those
current usages, those clicks,
back to the server, which
means that you want to batch
them up and upload them at the
same time as you're going
to do other, more
time-sensitive transfers.
So using a general pattern like
this one, you can ensure
that you're preempting
every next prefetch.
So if your user clicks on a
headline which you haven't
already downloaded, you're
going to need to ping the
server and grab that content.
That's a great time to initiate
the next prefetch, as
well, so the next bunch of
articles that the user may be
reading, as well as then
uploading all of your
analytics data.
So the trick here is to always
try and reduce the number of
times you turn on the radio to
initiate a transfer while
still avoiding wasting data.
So you don't want to download
data that you're
never going to use.
But if you do have the radio on,
it's a great opportunity
to try and download as
much as you can.
So we've been talking about
doing everything anonymously,
which is great.
It has some real advantages.
But there are always advantages
to actually knowing
who your user is.
So with the new Google+ sign-in
for Android, available
as part of Google Play services,
you can carry
preferences between devices
without your users needing to
create yet another username
and password.
And because it's social, you
can do clever things like
customize the news feeds which
are being displayed to each
user based on what their friends
are reading or what
their friends are finding
interesting.
So it's a great way of being
able to do that dynamic social
sharing as frictionless
as possible.
So our next step is to take a
closer look at today's apps
and see how close they are
to being pure Android.
To do that, we're going to
pass them through each of
these standard Pure Android
checklists.
The apps today were actually
pretty good.
So I think they stand an
excellent chance of getting
into this category.
And we'll certainly be working
with the developers to try and
help them better understand some
of the subtleties which
we're not able to fully describe
within our 30 minute
allocation.
So we'll be getting in touch
with these guys.
And hopefully we'll see some
updates in the near future.
Until then, you can find our
existing Pure Android
collection at
bit.ly/PureAndroid.
And you can nominate your app
for consideration by adding it
to our Trello page.
Just search for App Clinic
Trello and it will take you
right there.
Now, we're going to be back
later in the week to have a
look at podcast creation apps.
But the Android design and
action team are going to be
taking a break tomorrow.
So there will be no Android
design and action this week,
unfortunately.
But they will be
back next week.
So until Friday,
I'm Reto Meier.
And this has been
the App Clinic.